pandemic
and
a coordinated
fight against the virus itself and the
third section is devoted to sustainable
development
in the context of the
sustainable development goals
the main conclusion to be made from the
work of this summit
and not only on the level of leaders but
also the experts
who have coordinated the text
of a multi-page declaration
is that
attempts to promote
unilateral
approaches have met with no demand and
most participants
have voiced support
of a multilateral solutions that would
include a balance of interests both
relating to fighting the coronavirus
pandemic
and
maintaining
a livable climate
and energy security as well
has
clearly committed to
future solutions that will be based by a
clear sustainable balance
between suppliers
and consumers of energy resources
and as to climate
the paris agreement
logic
has been upheld
which is based on voluntary steps by
each state
to reduce the amount of emissions while
respecting national interests in the
field of economic development and
economic growth
so i think it's a very positive result
you will have a detailed look at the
declaration later today
but the main trends
that i think we should all support
as the aspiration towards collective
work and we've always supported that
the us navy has sent a command and
control ship to the black sea has russia
received an advance warning and how can
we assess such a step
well it's not about an advance warning
but it's about international law
regulating
entry of
international ships to the black sea
it's regulated by the montreux
convention
in accordance to which
the state
whose flag is borne by the navy ship
must
notify the relevant state
and as far as i know these
rules are observed
uh generally and as
regards the
navy ship
of the united states and black sea
that's not an isolated case
we've heard from them before that they
deem it necessary
to send their ships to the black sea to
contain russia to deter russia
and to reduce
risks
well it certainly does not
contribute to stability
and
the americans are trying to push
the countries around the black sea to uh
confrontational polit
political line
creating new military bases in romania
bulgaria would not
be conducive to good neighborship in the
black sea region
we're ready for
all kinds of direct threats
we don't have any
issues with uh securing
uh the russian territory
and the security
on the black
sea but we always
aim to promote
projects based on cooperation and not
confrontation
and it does not only involve
countries
along the coast but also other eu
and we always support
cooperation as the basis for our
interaction in this region
this week
moscow was visited by deputy foreign
minister of iran
and the iranian deal was discussed
and yesterday the future of the deal was
discussed by europeans and the united
states
is this revitalization of contact a sign
that all the parties will come back to
the deal and uh
can the deal be implemented without any
prerequisites
preconditions
well if other parties
wish to renew the deal
it can only be renewed
as it was approved by the u.n security
council in 2015.
any other solutions are acceptable to
the iranian side and we fully support
this approach
agreements should be
maintained in their original form
have there been any signals
on the part of nato
but the
need to renew a dialogue and is it
uh do you know who will be the nato
representatives in moscow
well your second question assumes that
the answer to your first question will
be positive but
all we have is facts and the facts are
that nato does not wish any interaction
with us
and even when we had a representative at
nato
they did not want
anything like that they just wanted to
teach us how to live
and they wanted to discuss ukraine
conduct propaganda and uh
put to blame for things on russia
so if
there are
any issues they want to discuss with us
they can go to our
ambassador in belgium
and we've notified nato that they can
send their signals through this diplomat
i don't know
uh
and then on u.s relationships with
russia did you meet with your
counterpart secretary
lincoln is there an opportunity
you can safely publish your questions
and inform your readers that you raise
these questions in front of me
on vaccines you would read
the declaration it is clear that the
leaders
want uh the mutual recognition of
certificates on
vaccination on
vaccines and physical presence i don't
see any any connection
many leaders today in their species
supported what president putin said on
vaccines
and uh
no i haven't seen tony blinken in in
rome i don't know whether he is here or
not but yesterday over dinner
we managed to talk with president biden
he did not send any regards so i cannot
subscribe to the
net zero by 2050 and how do we appraise
the work of the italian presidency on
the g20
uh
why why
do you believe 2050 is some
magic figure
now i want i want an answer because
you're asking the question uh being
convinced that 2050 is non-negotiable
you're right but uh 2050 was the
ambition put
forward by the european countries for
instance european union
and it was uh written in the the
initial
formulation of the communique
no no no look if it is an ambition of
the european union
then
other countries also have the right to
have ambitions
as for the communique
we highly appreciate the work by italian
presidency
they managed
just
this morning early this morning to help
negotiate and agree
the declaration which will be circulated
uh we would prefer though that the
original draft declaration be given to
us earlier than it was eventually
and the reason as we were explained
privately was that g7 negotiated the
drop declaration first
and then decided to circulate it to
others that's how the original
declaration contained 2050
as a date but it is not very
polite
to use this
negotiating process the way the g7 tried
to do
and if the media in italy
can is convinced that since the
european union and the united states and
g7 have an ambition to do it by 2050
and
if the italian media presents this as
the final truth
i i am afraid this is not respectful to
other members of g20 and to all other
members of international communities we
have calculated we don't like we don't
like to go
by empty ambitions and empty promises
european union promised to do away with
the russian gas pipelines
purchases and to buy all its needs on
the spot what happened with this
ambition we all know
so we have announced that we will do
this
we will
reach
carbon neutrality by
not later than 2016. this is our
calculated
commitment and we are sticking to it and
i stand to be corrected but nobody have
proven to us or to anybody else that
2050 is something which everybody must
subscribe
is
now
me
you